so this next speaker is one of my
students so i'm very happy to have him
on stage um and when i say students
we've tried like a decade ago i think at
this point right uh i think i'm going to
age both of us here i think it's been
like a decade um but i'm very excited
that it took me 10 years but he's going
to be speaking in front of this crew
here um he's actually been a very very
good friend of the meetup community um
his organizations um has hosted the
meetup for the meetup groups for the
workshops we've done so before you even
get to the stage a big round of applause
for all the help he's done for the
community too
um
and
he loves to scuba dive
and his favorite place to dive is costa
rica
and he has been face to face with a
tiger shark so you need to let us know
like in reference how big is a tiger
shark from this to jaws what are we
talking about
so please
welcome jorge
today's talk uh will be about healthcare
uh jared brought me in to give a little
bit of background on some of the work
i've done i've been 10 years in
healthcare probably more than that from
a you know graduate student
epidemiology phd student working on the
hospital sides at sloan kettering new
york presbyterian hospital the columbia
cornell medical centers and now my
recent hat is uh as a payer as aetna and
cvs
what i wanted to talk about was to give
some intuition on how we
should be thinking about readmission
predictions um in the context of quality
for hospitals so um the goal of this
talk will be to give you not just so
much like hey this is a state of the art
here's the aoc curve on good models but
really like when when are they useful
and how we should be thinking about
pairing a prediction with an
intervention um because uh i think i
start here with this slide which is to
say um you know us in the in
bioinformatics the the statistics or
data science uh phase we like to create
models and create complexity to try to
solve and get it interesting
segmentation or stratification or
identification but at the end of the day
we're not going to be doing the clinical
work we're it's it's in this space in
this picture which is the provider and
the patient that you kind of want to be
invisible you don't want to be
in there but you want to you want to
help inform and give enough tools or all
the tools all the information necessary
for the provider to um to act to respond
and to and to prevent so um that's sort
of the space that i want to discuss but
before we discuss on how to intervene um
i think it behooves us to understand
what are the contexts why why do we care
about um
hospital reduction readmissions where'd
this come from so i start with a little
bit of context and then we'll jump into
uh you know state of the art and how
some organizations and groups are
thinking about it
okay so um i think everyone saw this
mainly from the the abstract for the
talk so uh context outcomes population
timing of modeling and then
interventions right so that's sort of
the flow
so let's hit it um
okay so this first one if um if you go
to this website www.medicare.gov
care compare at the bottom
you'll find that cms centers for
medicaid medicare um right so what this
is this is government uh and and student
so cms has done an amazing job over the
past decade of um putting together what
is a tool to give patients insight to
give
whether you're looking for a doctor a
hospital a nursing home for an elderly
parent um hospice care
anything basically most of the
facilities that you search for care at
cms has done this tremendous job of
putting together a view
for someone who's not clinical to very
quickly surface hey which of these
providers which of these hospitals gives
me superior care for an uh for an
efficient cost so um this notion of
value is something that c cms uh started
you know more than a decade ago uh
passed with through the quote-unquote
obamacare but even before that it was a
lot of
wrangling and data collection getting to
a framework where you can actually um i
would say force hospitals to give this
data such that we can put together a
national vision and a tool like this so
it's no small feat very political very
technical um and but we're here so you
go to this website
and then i can search for a hospital say
i'm looking for an acute care hospital
for um
let's do knee and hip um and i'm here in
new york and lo and behold in the same
grid you know less than two miles three
miles away from each other there's two
hospitals um it i mean this is public so
i'm not calling out names uh elmhurst
hospital center uh and then hospitals
for special surgery and what we see here
is an incredible uh summarization and
quick jump into
uh hey this is a good or bad quality
hospital and hey the patient
satisfaction scores surveys that are on
our patients can uh represent the level
carrier expected to receive quality wise
and then the the hospital the care
services that you'll receive as a
patient your experience of being in
there and um
this is pretty uh pretty drawing that
you can have two hospitals so different
so close to each other in new york city
um but that's that's the truth that's
the true nature of the health care
system a lot of differences in care a
lot of uh imbalances and resources and
as a patient or as a as a care um you
know as a
someone who takes care of someone who's
sick or is fighting disease you know
these tools are here for us um and then
in this part of this whole system is one
of these measures or only sub components
i'm going to talk about which is the
hospital readmission measure that goes
into the start notion that says hey if
you're treated here you'll likely be
taken care of well inpatient and you're
likely to be connected to a system
that'll carry you through to get you
safely uh and back to your uh um you
know daily life activities right so so
this is this is sort of the motivation
and again how do we get there
um
and what am i really talking about right
so on the left hand side um is this
whole milieu of uh measures each one of
these measures has incredible validation
and two uh retrospective studies to uh
demonstrate that the measure is stable
that it can be reproduced and it's all
through the national quality foundation
um i showed maybe like 23 measures here
they have a catalog of over a thousand
and and they're constantly adding it's a
big area of research um and what i'm
calling out here is really these three
types of readmission rate uh acute
myocardial infarction remission rate
heart failure readmission rate pneumonia
um and but you see that there's there's
many many measures that get publicly
reported um and specifically for the
subset of readmission measures uh what
goes into this the secret sauce for this
measure is first the data collection so
you have more than 3 000 hospitals
naturally pushing data in on a quarterly
basis being assessed being collected um
you know that's where taxpayer dollars
go uh uh when they when they go to
medicare i mean this is this is
really difficult work to manage this
whole process um but then once you get
into this phase where okay i've
collected the readmissions uh using
standardized uh ingestion protocols then
we move to the next phase and this is
where cms believe they contract with
yelp to do this they take this and they
start making imprints over this data
right and i'll go into this uh in a
second but the idea is uh you create a
hierarchical model with all the
hospitals um uh and patients nested in
the hospital and then we collect uh
features that that are risk adjustment
they call case mix uh adjustment for uh
more complex patients less complex
patients and then um we
were able to rank the hospitals we were
able to compare the performance from the
uh you know uh very uh honorable or
lofty uh mayo clinics or hopkins down to
the community hospitals in idaho right
they're all put on the same standard um
and and we try to uh or the cms tries to
drive and it constantly increase
performance so you have the modeling you
have a standardization such that they're
comparable then you get these
distributions for um
uh risk ratios to say at 30 days uh
medicine surgical overall uh how is your
hospital performing and what cms does is
they draw a line all right line's down
here but um they draw a line they say if
you're on this side of the curve well um
you need to improve and what they do is
they apply a penalty a penalty which is
one percent um
and uh that motivates right so when
you're hitting the bottom line that
definitely causes motivation for
hospitals to enact processes to enact
procedures to deploy analytics teams to
roll out predictions that they can do
something with in order to
improve the performance not be on the
outlier side right
but the way this is structured
everyone's trying to improve all the
hospitals always because there's always
going to be someone on the right hand of
that curve but the implications are much
more profound than um this so-called uh
penalization or uh financial push to
improve quality in fact um
sorry uh in fact what happens is uh this
now becomes public so that same website
that i showed you um i'm making
decisions not to go to this hospital if
i can go to this other hospital uh some
cases you don't have that there they are
hospitals are monopolies in some regions
like they have one system um but if you
can choose you choose you can definitely
choose a at the provider level um so
there's public reporting uh new york
times write an article about you if
something's really awry um
then then this link's a reimbursement
but also commercial pairs private payers
have followed suit the big expression is
cms is the gorilla in the room whatever
they do sort of they suck the air out
and all the other players are like well
you know let's do that and in this case
cms paved the the road in order to drive
this big quality uh value driven care
initiative because this gets pushed back
but they're think they can they can
demand this because they they cover so
many lives so because of this private
pair is ensue um and then the the whole
notion here is that there's a lot of
incentives if you're a good performance
system good performing hospital and then
if you're a good hospital system with
good measures well then you also attract
a lot of the talent so so this is sort
of the thinking and how it goes um and
does it have an impact yeah definitely
does have an impact so this is in 2020
um this is the kaiser permanente health
network uh basically half the hospitals
receive some level of penalty and um you
know just to give you context a hospital
like new york presbyterian would
probably have 600 million uh might be
more now might be like 900 million um in
dollars from medicare so you're you're
getting a one percent hit annually
you're looking at somewhere between six
to nine million dollar penalty and that
could wipe out the margin for a month
right so you don't want to be there it
does hurt financially um and then um and
there's this push um however right or
or let's just say that uh
the
the fairness aspect of this is important
right i'll just say that sometimes small
hospitals have a hard time doing this
right because they don't have the
funding and then the question becomes
well do we penalize them on topic
they're already under funded that's why
they're not performing well so um the
the push has been to sort of understand
how to correctly adjust and what are the
right um sort of course matching levels
of hospitals that should be compared to
do this uh benchmark distribution and
assess a penalty so that's sort of the
conversation
okay but and then i believe this is my
last contact slide and then what we
think about is um
that there's this whole flow of care
right so when um when you're home and
you're at the gym all the way on the
left-hand side you have no acuity maybe
you start developing some comrades
hypertension diabetes see your doctor um
maybe you have a condition that that
keeps escalating and eventually you're
in the ed in the hospital right the the
correct path is then to uh you know go
to rehabilitation if it was a surgical
procedure go outpatient get out of the
the center get it home um or maybe you
need you're permanently gonna need some
help long-term this is this flow but the
idea is to return you back to healthier
activities um and in the general
situation this is the way it goes right
for the vast majority but as you age as
you get older or you have a chronic
disease uh sometimes that's not the case
sometimes you start seeing um this
recidivism back into the hospital so
instead of going all the way back to
home you jump back in this is the notion
of the readmission
um but not all of these are
preventable or avoidable sometimes you
reach the end of medicine so you're not
going to have the ability to to jump
back so again
the idea is to create an avoidable
30-day readmission this is a little
schematics but the idea is that if
you're admitted uh
let's let's create an inclusion criteria
where we can split you up into surgery
cardiovascular these different cohorts
um and then we assess an outcome and
then the outcome uh there are certain
things that might be planned for that
index event your hospitalized index
event um and then these are the things
that you don't want to penalize for but
you follow post discharge 30 days and
then you assess um if a hospital has a
thousand patients uh 30 of them came
back what's the rate how does this
compare to other hospitals that had a
thousand patients right so so this is
just defining the outcome there's an
exclusion there's a set of icd-10 codes
i'll talk about that one second that
will say if you if you're re-admitted
because of one of these it was planned
they're scoping you you're getting
follow-up care it's a good thing you're
back um you're now you're going to have
a surgery procedure it's going to
prevent the next one so so it's not
always bad it's only if it's avoidable
and there's there's good structure
around that and then the intuition here
is that um what you want to do is you
want to identify the patients that have
this risk that that because of the
milieu conditions of comorbidities or
contacts at home that uh
you can do something
hospitals have the largest budget in the
community there's many uh clinical
organizations in the community hospital
is the biggest budget they have the most
money to do something and organize and
partner so that's why it makes sense to
use hospital as a center to base these
programs um the idea here is um if you
have no um if you have no strategy then
basically you have some at-risk people
you don't know and uh you're getting
penalized it's costing you money uh
private and and government payers will
not pay for some of it or penalize you
so the and it's costing you money right
you're you're not you're not putting in
maybe much more lucrative procedures and
you have a readmission for a sick
patient that's not reimbursable so
there's there's motivation all
throughout to fix this to act on this so
the idea here is then well okay well
let's uh let's not differentiate the
population and let's just uh swab and
prevent uh infections in the hospital uh
generalized uh and then that should
reduce by some level right you say you
drop off two patients some level of
benefit is observed um the idea here is
that maybe some people didn't need this
intervention right or you're spending
money or you're not spending enough
money in some groups to prevent it so
this is lo and behold
where risk profile patients come in and
this is the notion of readmission that
this is now denoted by different colors
if you're really sick
um you you kind of want a differentiated
intervention and this is this is what uh
predictive modeling in the impression
setting lets you do it says these people
will be fine these second people if you
intervene a certain way you'll reduce uh
if you intervene another way for the
most at risk you'll reduce but you'll
never reduce it to zero so there it's
just it's just the nature of medicine
some people it is quote unquote third
time but this is the underlying
intuition um and as you benchmark uh and
and then now as you create predictions
to segment and treat differently um you
want to take account into the
differences of the individuals right so
how do we do this right how do we cut
out the populations that matter first
what are the populations um this is a
quick snapshot of a report that a
hospital would get from cms um just
a lot of information i just wanted to be
in the deck so you can see it later but
a hospital will get this report for uh
myocardial it's heart attack copd heart
failure pneumonia um cabbage and total
hip uh uh knee and um hip and knee
replacement so these two are surgical
procedures that should not have a
readmission and then you should be able
to manage these four conditions very
well such that they're not readmitted so
this is fair game what's been allowed in
um in the rule books right now and then
you get this note this modeling of what
is your predicted uh what is your
expected and what's this access amount
this is the foundation of of how you're
going to be judged on benchmark and uh
how cms is doing it now how do they get
this predicted readmission
um
you're you're in this modeling framework
right so you create a generalized linear
model uh so i know there's statistical
teams here but the the gist here is that
you have a matrix of information here
that the bzij which is hospital j and um
patients i and you're going to adjust
for uh comorbidities so conditions that
would also drive the individual to
individual patient to be readmitted and
then you fit a random effect for a
hospital and this data and these risk
resistant factors are very important to
differentiate this hospital treats
sicker patients in that hospital so when
we compare it has we need to give
hospitals credit for the care that they
give and that's the idea why we do this
model and then we fit the random
intercept for a hospital effect we don't
have um
they don't include hospital
characteristics per se in this model um
but but we get the patient
characteristics but we do allow for a
random intercept and then we do an
indirect standardization such that we
get apple samples comparison right so
this is sort of behind the scene what
cms is doing and and the feature is an
example of the features they're based on
icd-10 codes right so here's um
endocrine metabolic disorder this is a
mapping from icd-10 codes uh diagnosis
codes into this grouper this aggregate
uh mapper that maps codes to an ontology
that we put in a binary feature and then
it fits into this hierarchical model so
this thing increases risk of readmission
right um basically all they all increase
risk we don't we're not modeling
preventive preventative effects this is
all from methodology from cms papers so
um and then
i'll say
that more or less the the
c-statistic on these models is around
75. so a lot of the times when we talk
about modeling here and i'll show you
now even as we get more advanced um
you're not beating this readmission
prediction at 30 days but more than you
know 70 75 80 max that i've seen for
area under the curve overseas statistics
because a lot of what happens half the
battle or what literally 25 of the
battle doesn't happen in the inpatient
setting it happens with the connection
post right because you have 30 days
where people are on their own but a lot
of it is controlled by the inpatient
setting that's 75
um but a lot is not right so so this is
the world that we live in hospitals are
have the mandate to to intervene and
have budgets to intervene so then that
becomes a question how do we pull this
all together so
now just to give you a quick notion of i
have timing on top but um the idea is
now that uh
this this is a standard uh type of
readmission prevention or readmission
prediction paper that a hospital group
would pull pull out this is uh will
cornell a lot of a lot of different uh
groups that put this together now
instead of just claims you're using
electronic health records so this is
labs and
medical notes and a rich assessment of
other data
and what they do is at discharge
or at admission you know something at
discharge you know a bit about the
individual and you create uh different
types of ensemble models to try to
predict what um you know what is the
risk of this patient um in terms of um
coming back in i believe this is what
we're looking at three thousand or so
patients um okay and so what you get is
this right so uh this is a 30 day model
it's a readmission at 30 days this is
heart failure cohort around 3 000 and
change patients this is alchemist
readmission um at six months and the
idea here is you have slices of data at
the index so when you're admitted you
know some some information some red
blood cell measures some hemoglobin
measure then at discharge you've treated
the patient now you have a delta you
have a a final state
you can aggregate the features take
means take exponential smoothers you
could do many many many different things
and then you started saying okay well uh
this measured here measured here now i
can predict um and then again you're
still looking at um you know different
information at different time points but
it's not great it's not it's not really
good classification by by any means it
could be improved but this is this is
the state of affairs in terms of how we
um
how we can predict let me see where
we're at yeah so this is how we can
predict and get at uh the risk um
the
if i if i tell you that cutting edge is
this was the google uh deep learning
paper a 2008 um so they used billions of
i believe a billion uh discharges from
different uh medical systems and they're
also looking at this um you know more or
less 70 77 76 percent uh readmission um
prediction capability but so then
where's the secret sauce right i think
it's this and this is this is the what i
want to leave you with right um
this is this is a mediation framework um
and then the idea here is that as we
start
as we start looking at what is your risk
of an event you also want to look at the
context so this this is in this um this
framework of you have geography these
are this is the risk adjustment factors
demographics uh the per member per month
spend utilization prior to an event um
but then we want to look at uh want to
look at what are the contexts right what
are the standard of uh social
determinants of health are there
barriers that you cannot uh uh that the
patient themselves can't overcome well
if so then let's intervene let's give
them money for an uber right let's get
them some uh discounted medications so
they can improve adherence right there
are there are many things that uh let's
get a hospital to their home and pay for
it because it will likely be cheaper so
just to give you context i think this is
where most of the hospitals most of the
providers are now considering is to say
let's take this environment and let's
turn it into causal framework and let's
start experiencing given a risk or how
much can we mediate through one of their
um one of one of their elements that
would reduce impactability and then this
is this is area where um research is
ongoing what are the right interventions
piloting different interventions and
you'll find that a lot of hospitals who
have assumed more of their risk
start thinking and saying um let's let's
spend some more than what we normally do
because if we intervene on these on
these mediating pathways of risk then we
can have an impact to reduce readmission
to reduce mortality to do to connect um
and a lot of these are a further
connection with partners in the
community right um so i think this is
where we go that's a message on a land
on um and then um of course doctors like
anything that can help you help them
save money and then finally i'll say a
lot of tools
have been implemented right you have to
you have to think about the system to
intervene on in order to drive change
and do impact i challenge you to read
this article a lot of innovation in ai
for covet didn't really help so how can
we be more helpful and how can we um
facilitate that relationship between the
provider and the patient
i'll stop there i hope i sparked some
curiosity to read more um thank you
everyone